[Music]
the party was dull
i had come too early there was a preview
that night at grauman's chinese
and few of the important guests would
arrive until it was over
jack hardy ace director at summit
pictures where i worked as assistant
director
hadn't arrived yet and he was the host
but hardy had never been noted for
punctuality
i went out on the porch and leaned
against a railing and looked down at the
lights of hollywood
hardy's place was on the summit of a
hill overlooking the film capital
near falcon lair valentino's famous
turreted castle
i shivered a little fogg was sweeping in
from santa monica
blotting out the lights to the west gene
hubbard who was an ingenuity summit
came up beside me and took the glass out
of my hand
hello mark she said sipping the liquor
where have you been
down with the murder desert troop on
location in the mojave
i said miss me honey i drew her close
she smiled up at me her tilted eyebrows
lending a touch of the diabolical to the
tanned lovely face
i was going to marry jean but i wasn't
sure just when
missed you lots she said and held up her
lips
i responded after a moment i said
what's this about the vampire man she
chuckled
oh the chevalier futane didn't you read
lolly parsons write up in script
jack hardy picked him up last month in
europe silly rot
still it's good publicity three cheers
for publicity i said
look what it did for birth of a nation
but where does the vampire angle come in
mystery man nobody can take a picture of
him scarcely anybody can meet him
weird tales are told about his former
life in paris
he's going to play in red thirst the
kind of build-up universal gave karloff
for frankenstein
our chevalier futane she rolled out the
words with amused relish
is probably a singing waiter from a
paris cafe
i haven't seen him but the deuce with
him anyway
mark i want you to do something for me
for deming
hess deming i raised my eyebrows in
astonishment
hess deming summit's biggest box office
star
whose wife sandra coulter had died two
days before
she too had been an actress although
never the great star her husband was
hess loved her i knew and now i guessed
what the trouble was
i said i noticed he was a bit wobbly
he'll kill himself gene said looking
worried
i feel responsible for him somehow mark
after all he gave me my start at summit
and he's due for the dts any time now
well i'll do what i can i told her but
that isn't a great deal
after all getting tight is probably the
best thing he could do
i know if i lost you gene i stopped
i didn't like to think of it gene nodded
see what you can do for him anyway
losing sondra that way was
pretty terrible what way i asked
i've been away remember i read something
about it but
she just died jean said pernicious
anemia they said
but hess told me the doctor really
didn't know what it was she just seemed
to grow weaker and weaker until
she passed away i nodded gave jean a
hasty kiss
and went back into the house i had just
seen hes deming walk
past a glass in his hand he turned as i
tapped his shoulder
oh mark he said his voice just a bit
fuzzy
he could hold his liquor but i could
tell by his bloodshot eyes that he was
almost at the end of his rope
he was a handsome devil alright well
built strong featured
with level gray eyes and a broad mouth
that was usually smiling
it wasn't smiling now it was slack and
his face was bedeawed with perspiration
you know about sandra he asked yeah
i said i'm sorry hess he drank deeply
from the glass
wiped his mouth with a grimace of
distaste i'm drunk mark
he confided i had to get drunk it was
awful
those last few days i've gotta burn her
up
i didn't say anything burn her up
oh my god mark that beautiful body of
hers crumbling to ash
and i've gotta watch it she made me
promise i'd watch to make sure they
burned her
i said cremation's a clean ending hess
and sandra was a clean girl and a damned
good actress
he put his flushed face close to mine
yeah
but i've gotta burn her up it'll kill me
mark oh god
he put the empty glass down on a table
and looked around dazedly
i was wondering why sandra had insisted
on cremation
she'd given an interview once in which
she stressed her dread of fire
most write-ups of stars are applesauce
but i happen to know that sandra did
dread fire
once on the set i'd seen her go into
hysterics when her leading man lit his
pipe too near her face
excuse me mark has said i've got to get
another drink
wait a minute i said holding him you
want to watch yourself hess
you've had too much already it still
hurts
he said just a little more and maybe it
won't hurt so much
but he didn't pull away instead he
stared at me with a dullness of
intoxication in his eyes
clean he said presently she said that
too mark
she said burning was a clean death but
god that beautiful white body of hers
i can't stand it mark i'm going crazy i
think
get me a drink like a good fellow i said
wait here hess i'll get you one
i didn't add that it would be watered
considerably
he sank down in a chair mumbling thanks
as i went off i felt sick
i'd seen too many actors going on the
rocks to mistake hess's symptoms
i knew that his box office days were
over there would be longer and longer
waits between features
and then personal appearances and
finally poverty row and cereals
and in the end maybe a man found dead in
a cheap hall bedroom on main street with
the gas on
there was a crowd around the bar
somebody said
here's mark hey come on and meet the
vampire
then i got a shock i saw jack hardy my
host
the director with whom i'd had many a
hit he looked like a corpse
and i'd seen him looking plenty poorly
before a man with a hangover or a
marijuana jag
isn't a pretty sight but i'd never seen
hardy like this
he looked as though he was keeping going
on his nerve alone there was no blood in
the man
i'd last seen him as a stocky ruddy
blonde who looked like nothing so much
as a wrestler
with his huge biceps his ugly
good-natured face
and his bristling crop of yellow hair
now he looked like a skeleton
with skin hanging loosely on the big
frame his face was a network of sagging
wrinkles
pouches bagged beneath his eyes and
those eyes were dull and glazed
about his neck a black silk scarf was
nodded tightly
good god jack i exclaimed what have you
done to yourself
he looked away quickly nothing he said
bruskly
i'm all right i want you to meet the
chevalier footain
this is mark prescott pierre a voice
said
hollywood is no place for titles mark
prescott
the pleasure is mine i faced the
chevalier pierre futene
we shook hands my first impression was
of icy cold
and a slick kind of dryness and i let go
of his hand too quickly to be polite
he smiled at me a charming man the
chevalier
or so he seemed slender below medium
height
his bland round face seemed
incongruously youthful
blond hair was plastered close to his
scalp
i saw that his cheeks were rouged very
deftly but i know something about makeup
and under the rouge i read a curious
deathly pallor that would have made him
a marked man had he not disguised it
some disease perhaps had blanched his
skin but his lips were not artificially
reddened
and they were as crimson as blood he was
clean-shaven
wore impeccable evening clothes and his
eyes were black pools of ink
glad to know you i said you're the
vampire eh
he smiled so they tell me but we all
serve the dark god of publicity hey mr
prescott
or is it mark it's mark i said still
staring at him
i saw his eyes go past me and an
extraordinary
expression appeared on his face an
expression of amazement
disbelief swiftly it was gone
i turned jean was approaching was at my
side as i moved
she said is this the chevalier
pierre futene was staring at her his
lips parted a little
almost inaudibly he murmured sonia
and then on a note of interrogation
sonia
i introduced the two gene said you see
my name isn't sonia the chevalier shook
his head
an odd look in his black eyes i once
knew a girl like you
he said softly very much like you it's
strange
will you excuse me i broke in jack hardy
was leaving the bar
quickly i followed him i touched his
shoulder as he went out the french
windows
he jerked out a snarled oath turned a
white death mask of a face to me
damn you mark he snarled keep your hands
to yourself
i put my hands on his shoulders and
swung him around what the devil has
happened to you
i asked listen jack you can't bluff me
or lie to me
you know that i've straightened you out
enough times in the past and i can do it
again
let me in on it his ruined face softened
he reached up and took away my hands his
own were ice cold
like the hands of the chevalier footain
no he said no use mark there's nothing
you can do
i'm all right really just over strain
i had too good a time in paris i was up
against a blank wall
suddenly without volition a thought
popped into my mind and out of my mouth
before i knew it
what's the matter with your neck i asked
abruptly
he didn't answer he just frowned and
shook his head
i have a throat infection he told me i
caught it on the steamer
his hand went up and touched the black
scarf
there was a croaking harsh sound from
behind us a sound that didn't seem quite
human
i turned it was hess deming he was
swaying in the portal
his eyes glaring in bloodshot a little
trickle of saliva running down his chin
he said in a dead expressionless voice
that was somehow dreadful
sandra died of a throat infection hardy
jack didn't answer he stumbled back a
step
hess went on dully she got all white and
died
and the doctor didn't know what it was
although the death certificate said
anemia
did you bring back some filthy disease
with you hardy because if you did
i'm going to kill you wait a minute i
said
a throat infection i didn't know
there was a wound on her throat two
little marks close together
that wouldn't have killed her unless
some loathsome disease
you're crazy hess i said you know you're
drunk
listen to me jack couldn't have had
anything to do with that
hess didn't look at me he watched jack
hardy out of his bloodshot
eyes he went on in that low deadly
monotone
will you swear mark's right hearty will
you
jack's lips were twisted by some inner
agony
i said go on jack tell him he's wrong
hearty burst out i haven't been near
your wife i haven't seen her since i got
back
there's that's not the answer i want
hess whispered and he sprang for the
other or reeled forward rather
hess was too drunk and jacked too weak
for them to do each other any harm
but there was a nasty scuffle for a
moment before i separated them
as i pulled them apart hess's hand
clutched the scarf about jack's neck and
ripped it away
and i saw the marks on jack hardy's
throat
two red angry little pits white rimmed
just over the jugular
it was the next day that gene telephoned
me
mark she said we're going to run over a
scene for red thirst tonight at the
studio
stage six you've been assigned as
assistant director for the pick so you
should be there
and i had an idea jack might not tell
you he's been
so odd lately thanks honey i said
i'll be there but i didn't know you were
in the flicker
neither did i but there's been some wire
pulling somebody wanted me in it
the chevalier i think and the big boss
phoned me this morning and let me in on
the secret
i don't feel up to it though i had a bad
night
sorry i sympathized you were okay when i
left you i had a
nightmare she said slowly it was rather
frightful mark
it's funny though i can't remember what
it was about well
you'll be there tonight i said i would
but as it happened i was unable to keep
my
promise hess deming telephoned me asking
if i'd come out to his malibu place and
drive him into town
he was too shaky to handle a car himself
he said
and saunders cremation was to take place
that afternoon
i got out my roadster and sent it
spinning west on sunset
in 20 minutes i was at deming's beach
house the houseboy let me in
shaking his head gravely as he
recognized me
mr deming's pretty bad he told me all
morning drinking gin straight
from upstairs has shouted that you mark
okay i'll be down right away come up
here jim
the servant with a meaningful glance at
me pattered upstairs
i wandered over to a table examining the
magazines upon it
a little breeze of wind came through the
half open window fluttering a scrap of
paper
a word on it caught my eye and i picked
up the note
for that's what it was it was addressed
to hess
and after one glance i had no
compunction about scanning it
hess dear the message read i feel i'm
going to die very soon
and i want you to do something for me
i've been out of my head i know
saying things i didn't mean don't
cremate me hess
even though i'll be dead i'd feel the
fire i know it
bury me in a vault in forest lawn and
don't embalm me
i shall be dead when you find this but i
know you'll do as i wish dear
and alive or dead i'll always love you
the note was signed by sandra coulter as
his wife
i wondered whether hess had seen it yet
there was a little hiss of in-drawn
breath from behind me
it was jim the houseboy he said
mr prescott i found that note last night
mr hess hasn't seen it
it's miss coulter's writing he hesitated
and i read fear in his eyes
sheer unashamed fear he put his
forefinger on the note
see that mr prescott he was pointing to
a smudge of ink that half obscured the
signature
i said well i did that mr prescott when
i picked up the note
the ink it wasn't dry i stared at him
he turned hastily at the sound of
footsteps on the stairs
hess deming was coming down rather
shakily
i think it was then that i first
realized the horrible truth
i didn't believe it though not then it
was too fantastic
too incredible yet something of the
truth must have crept into my mind
for there was no other explanation for
what i did then
hess said what have you got there mark
nothing
i said quietly i crumpled the note and
thrust it into my pocket
nothing important anyway ready to go
he nodded and we went to the door i
caught a glimpse of jim staring after us
an expression of was it relief on his
dark wizard face
the crematory was in pasadena and i left
hess there
i would have stayed with him but he
wouldn't have it i knew he didn't want
anyone to be watching him when sandra's
body was being incinerated
and i knew it would be easier for him
that way i took a shortcut through the
hollywood hills
and that's where the trouble started i
broke an axel
recent reigns had gullied the road and i
barely saved the car from turning over
after that i had to hike miles to the
nearest telephone
and then i wasted more time waiting for
a taxi to pick me up
it was nearly eight o'clock when i
arrived at the studio
the gateman let me in and i hurried to
stage six
it was dark cursing out of my breath i
turned away
and almost collided with a small figure
it was forrest one of the cameramen
he let out a curious squeal and clutched
my arm
that you mark listen will you do me a
favor
i want you to watch some footage i
haven't time i said
have you seen gene around here i was
supposed to
it's about that forrest said he was a
shriveled monkey-faced little chap
but a mighty good cameraman they've gone
gene and hardy and the chevalier
there's something funny about that guy
think so
well i'll phone gene i'll look at your
rushes tomorrow
she won't be home he told me the
chevalier took her over to the grove
listen mark you've gotta watch this
either i don't know how to handle a
camera anymore or that frenchman is the
damnedest thing i've ever shot
come over to the theater i've got the
reel ready to run
just developed the rough print myself oh
all right
i assented and followed forest to the
theater
i found a seat in the dark little
auditorium and listened to forrest
moving about in the projection booth
he clicked on the amplifier and said
hardy didn't want any pictures taken
insisted on it you know but the boss
told me to leave one of the automatic
cameras going
not to bother with the sound just to get
an idea how the french guy would screen
lucky it wasn't one of the old rattler
cameras or hardy would have caught on
here it comes mark i heard a click as
the amplifier was switched off
white light flared on the screen it
faded
gave place to a picture the interior of
stage six
the set was incongruous a mid-victorian
parlor
with overstuffed plush chairs
guilt-edged paintings
even a particularly hideous whatnot jack
hardy moved into the range of the camera
on the screen his face seemed to leap
out at me like a death's head
covered with sagging wrinkled skin
following him
came jean wearing a tailored suit no one
dresses for rehearsals
and behind her i blinked thinking that
my eyes were tricking me
something like a glowing fog oval tall
as a man
was moving across the screen you've seen
the nimbus of light on the screen when a
flashlight is turned directly on the
camera well it was like that
except that its source was not traceable
and horribly it moved forward at about
the pace a man would walk
the amplifier clicked again forrest said
when i saw it on the negative i thought
i was screwy mark i saw the take
there wasn't any funny light there the
oval glowing haze was motionless beside
jean
and she was looking directly at it a
smile on her lips
mark when that was taken jean was
looking right at the french guy
i said somewhat hoarsely hold it forest
right there
the images slowed down became motionless
gene's profile was toward the camera i
leaned forward
staring at something i had glimpsed on
the girl's neck it was scarcely visible
save as a tiny discolored mark on jean's
throat
above the jugular but unmistakably the
same wound i had seen on the throat of
jack hardy the night before
i heard the amplifier click off suddenly
the screen showed blindingly white
and then went black i waited a moment
but there was no sound from the booth
forest i called you okay
there was no sound the faint whirring of
the projector had died
i got up quickly and went to the back of
the theater
there were two entrances to the booth a
door which opened on stairs leading down
to the alley outside
and a hole in the floor reached by means
of a metal ladder
i went up this swiftly an ominous
apprehension mounting within me
forrest was still there but he was no
longer alive
he lay sprawled on his back his wizard
face staring up blindly
his head twisted at an impossible angle
it was quite apparent that his neck had
been broken
almost instantly i sent a hasty glance
at the projector
the can of film was gone and the door
opening on the stairway was ajar a few
inches
i stepped out on the stairs although i
knew i would see no one
the white-lit broad alley between stages
six and four
was silent and empty the sound of
running feet came to me
steadily growing louder a man came
racing into view
i recognized him as one of the publicity
gang i hailed him
can't wait he gasped but slowed down
nevertheless
i said have you seen anyone around here
just now the chevalier footain
he shook his head no but his face was
white as he looked up at me
hess deming's gone crazy i've got to
contact the papers
ice gripped me i raced down the stairs
clutched his arm
what do you mean i snapped hess was all
right when i left him
a bit tight that's all his face was
glistening with sweat
it's awful i'm not sure yet what
happened his wife
sandra coulter came to life while they
were cremating her
they saw her through the window you know
screaming and pounding at the glass
while she was being burned alive
hess got her out too late he went stark
raving mad
suspended animation they say i've got to
get to a phone mr prescott
he tore himself away sprinted in the
direction of the administration
buildings
i put my hand in my pocket and pulled
out a scrap of paper
it was the note i had found at hess
deming's house the words danced and
wavered before my eyes
over and over i was telling myself it
can't be true
such things can't happen i didn't mean
sandra coulter's terrible resurrection
during the cremation that alone might be
plausibly explained
catalepsy perhaps but taken in
conjunction with certain other
occurrences
it led to one definite conclusion and it
was a conclusion i dared not face
what had poor forest said that the
chevalier was taking gene to coconut
grove
well the taxi was still waiting i got in
the ambassador i told the driver grimly
20 bucks if you hit the green lights all
the way
all night i had been combing hollywood
without success
neither the chevalier futane nor jean
had been to the grove i discovered
and no one knew the chevalier's address
a telephone call to the studio
now ablaze with the excitement over the
hess deming disaster
and the forest killing netted me exactly
nothing
i went the rounds of hollywood nightlife
vainly the trocadero
sardis all three of the brown derbies
the smart notorious clubs of the sunset
80s
nowhere could i find my quarry i
telephoned jack hardy a dozen times but
got no answer
finally in a private club in culver city
i met with my first stroke of good luck
mr hardy's upstairs the proprietor told
me looking anxious
nothing wrong i hope mr prescott i heard
about deming
nothing i said take me up to him
he's sleeping it off the man admitted
tried to drink the place dry
and i put him upstairs where he'd be
safe not the first time eh
i said with an assumption of lightness
well bring up some coffee will you
black i've gotta talk to him
but it was half an hour before hardy was
in any shape to understand what i was
saying at last he sat up on the couch
blinking
and a gleam of realization came into his
sunken eyes
prescott he said can't you leave me
alone
i leaned close to him articulating
carefully so that he would be sure to
understand me
i know what the chevalier foutein is i
said
and i waited for the dreadful impossible
confirmation
or for the words which would convince me
that i was an insane fool
hardy looked at me dully how did you
find out
he whispered an icy shock went through
me
up to that moment i had not really
believed in spite of all the evidence
but now hardy was confirming the
suspicions which i had not let myself
believe
i didn't answer his question instead i
said
do you know about hess he nodded and at
the sight of the agony in his face i
almost pitied him
then the thought of gene steadied me do
you know where he is now
i asked no what are you talking about
he flared suddenly are you mad mark do
you
i'm not mad but hess deming is he looked
at me like a cowering whipped dog
i went on grimly are you gonna tell me
the truth
how you got those marks on your throat
how you met this creature
and where he's taken gene gene
he looked genuinely startled has he got
i didn't know that mark i swear i didn't
you've been a good friend to man
and i'll tell you the truth for your
sake and jeans
although now it may be too late my
involuntary movement made him glance at
me quickly
then he went on i met him in paris
i was out after new sensations but i
didn't expect anything like that
a satanist club devil worshipers they
were
the ordinary stuff cheap furtive
blasphemy
but it was there that i met him he can
be a fascinating chap when he tries
he drew me out made me tell him about
hollywood about the women we have here
i bragged a little he asked me about the
stars
whether they were really as beautiful as
they seemed his eyes were hungry as he
listened to me mark
then one night i had a fearful nightmare
a monstrous black horror crept in
through the window and attacked me
bit me in the throat i dreamed or
thought i did
after that i was in his power he told me
the truth
he made me his slave and i could do
nothing his powers
they're not human i licked dry lips
hardy continued he made me bring him
here
introducing him as a new discovery to be
starring in red thirst
i'd mention the picture to him before i
knew
how he must have laughed at me he made
me serve him
keeping away photographers making sure
that there were no cameras no mirrors
near him
and for a reward he let me live
i knew i should feel contempt for hardy
panderer to such a loathsome evil
but somehow i couldn't i said quietly
what about gene where does the chevalier
live
he told me but you can't do anything
mark there's a vault under the house
where he stays during the day
it can't be opened except with a key
that he always keeps with him
a silver key he had a door specially
made
and then did something to it so that
nothing can open it but that key
even dynamite wouldn't do it he told me
i said such things can be killed
not easily sandra coulter was a victim
of his
after death she too became a vampire
sleeping by day and living only at night
the fire destroyed her but there's no
way to get into the vault under futine's
house
i wasn't thinking of fire i said a knife
through the heart hardy interrupted
almost eagerly yes
and decapitation i've thought of it
myself but i can do nothing
i'm his slave mark i said nothing but
press the bell
presently the proprietor appeared can
you get me a butcher knife
i measured with my hands about so long a
sharp one
accustomed to strange requests he nodded
right away mr prescott
as i followed him out hardy said weekly
mark
i turned good luck he said
the look on his wrecked face robbed the
words of their pathos
thanks i forced myself to say i don't
blame you jack for what's happened
i'd have done the same i left him there
slumped on the couch staring after me
with eyes that had looked into hell
it was past daylight when i drove out of
culver city a long razor edge knife
hidden securely inside my coat
and the day went past all too quickly a
telephone call told me that gene had not
yet returned home
it took me more than an hour to locate a
certain man i wanted
a man who had worked for the studio
before on certain delicate jobs
there was little about locks he did not
know as the police had sometimes
ruefully admitted
his name was axel ferguson a bulky
good-natured swede
whose thick fingers seemed more adapted
to handling a shovel than the mechanisms
of locks
yet he was his expert as houdini indeed
he had at one time been a professional
magician
the front door of futene's isolated
canyon home proved no bar to ferguson's
fingers and the tiny sliver of steel he
used
the house a modern two-story place
seemed deserted
but hardy had said below the house
we went down the cellar stairs and found
ourselves in a concrete-lined passage
that ran down at a slight angle for
perhaps 30 feet
there the corridor ended in what seemed
to be a blank wall of bluish steel
the glossy surface of the door was
unbroken save for a single keyhole
set to work at first he hummed under his
breath
but after a time he worked in silence
sweat began to glisten on his face
trepidation assailed me as i watched the
flashlight he had placed beside him grew
dim
he inserted another battery got out
unfamiliar-looking apparatus
he buckled on dark goggles and handed me
a pair
a blue intensely brilliant flame began
to play on the door
it was useless the torch was discarded
after a time
and ferguson returned to his tools he
was using a stethoscope
taking infinite pains in the delicate
movements of his hands
it was fascinating to watch him but all
the time i realized that the night
was coming that presently the sun would
go down and that the life of the vampire
lasts from sunset to sunrise
at last ferguson gave up i can't do it
he told me panting is though from a hard
race and if
i can't nobody can even houdini couldn't
have broken this lock
the only thing that'll open it is that
key alright axel
i said dully here's your money he
hesitated watching me
you going to stay here mr prescott yeah
i said you can find your way out i'll
wait a while well i'll leave the light
with you
he said you can let me have it sometime
eh
he waited and as i made no answer he
departed shaking his head
then utter silence closed around me i
took the knife out of my coat
tested its edge against my thumb and
settled back to wait
less than half an hour later the steel
door began to swing open
i stood up through the widening crack i
saw a bare steel line chamber
empty save for a long black object that
rested on the floor
it was a coffin the door was wide
interview moved a white slender figure
jean
clad in a diaphanous silken robe her
eyes were wide
fixed and staring she looked like a
sleepwalker
a man followed her a man wearing
impeccable evening clothes
not a hair was out of place on his sleek
blonde head
and he was touching his lips delicately
with a handkerchief as he came out of
the vault
there was a little crimson stain on the
white linen where his lips had brushed
jean walked past me as though i didn't
exist but the chevalier futane paused
his eyebrows lifted his black eyes
pierced through me
the handle of the knife was hot in my
hand i moved aside to block futane's way
behind me came a rustle of silk and from
the corner of my eye i saw gene pause
hesitatingly
the chevalier eyed me toying negligently
with his handkerchief
mark he said slowly mark prescott
his eyes flickered toward the knife and
a little smile touched his lips
i said you know why i'm here don't you
yes he said i heard you i was not
disturbed
only one thing can open this door from
his pocket he drew a key
shining with a dull silver sheen only
this
he finished replacing it your knife is
useless mark prescott
maybe i said edging forward very
slightly
what have you done to gene a curious
expression
almost of pain flashed into his eyes she
is mine
he shot out half angrily you can do
nothing
i sprang then or at least i tried to the
blade of the knife sheared down
straight for futene's white shirt front
it was arrested in mid-air
yet he had not moved his eyes had bored
into mine
suddenly terribly and it seemed as
though a wave of fearful energy had
blasted out at me
paralyzing me rendering me helpless i
stood rigid
veins throbbed in my temples as i tried
to move to bring down the knife
it was useless i stood as immoveable as
a statue
the chevalier brushed past me follow
he said almost casually and like an
automaton i swung about
began to move along the passage what
hellish hypnotic power was this that
held me helpless
futine led the way upstairs it was not
yet dark although the sun had gone down
i followed him into a room and had his
gesture dropped into a chair
at my side was a small table the
chevalier touched my arm gently
and something like a mild electric shock
went through me
the knife dropped from my fingers
clattering to the table
jean was standing rigidly nearby her
eyes dull and expressionless
futine moved to her side put an arm
around her waist
my mouth felt as though it were filled
with mud but somehow i managed to croak
out articulate words
damn you futine leave her alone
he released her and came toward me his
face dark with anger
you fool i could kill you now very
easily i could make you go down to the
busiest corner of hollywood and slit
your throat with that knife
i have that power the face of a beast
looking into mine
he snarled she is not yours nor is she
jean she is sonja i remembered what
futine had murmured when he had first
seen gene
he read the question in my eyes i knew a
girl like that once
very long ago that was sonja they killed
her
put a stake through her heart long ago
in thurne
now that i've found this girl who might
be a reincarnation of sonia
they are so alike i shall not give her
up nor can anyone force me
you've made her a devil like yourself i
said through half paralyzed lips
i'd rather kill her futane turned to
watch
jean not yet he said softly
she is mine yes she bears the stigmata
but she is still alive she will not
become
a vampire until she has died or until
she has tasted the red milk
she shall do that tonight i cursed him
bitterly
foully he touched my lips and i could
utter no sound
then they left me jean and her master i
heard a door close quietly
the night dragged on futile struggles
had convinced me that it was useless to
attempt escape
i could not even force a whisper through
my lips
more than once i felt myself on the
verge of madness
thinking of gene and remembering
futine's ominous words
eventually agony brought its own cerseis
and i fell into a kind of coma
lasting for how long i could not guess
many hours had passed i knew
before i heard footsteps coming toward
my prison
gene moved into my range of vision i
searched her face with my eyes
seeking for some mark of a dreadful
metamorphosis
i could find none her beauty was
unmarred
save for the terrible little wounds on
her throat she went to a couch and
quietly lay down
her eyes closed the chevalier came past
me
and went to gene's side he stood looking
down at her
i have mentioned before the incongruous
youthfulness of his face
that was gone now he looked old old
beyond imagination
at last he shrugged and turned to me his
fingers brushed my lips again and i
found that i could speak
life flooded back into my veins benign
lancing twinges of pain
i moved an arm experimentally the
paralysis was leaving me
the chevalier said she is still clean
i could not do it amazement flooded me
my eyes widened in disbelief
futine smiled riley it is quite true
i could have made her as myself undead
but at the last moment i forbade her he
looked toward the windows
it will be dawn soon i glanced at the
knife on the table beside me
the chevalier put out a hand and drew it
away
wait he said there is something i must
tell you mark prescott
you say that you know who and what i am
i nodded
through the ages i have come since first
i fell victim to another vampire
for thus is the evil spread deathless
and not alive
bringing fear and sorrow always knowing
the bitter agony of tantalus
i have gone down through the weary
centuries i have known richard and henry
and elizabeth of england
and ever have i brought terror and
destruction in the night
for i am an alien thing i am the undead
the quiet voice went on holding me
motionless in its weird spell
i the vampire i the accursed the shining
evil
negotium perambulans and tenebrus but i
was not always thus
long ago in thurn before the shadow
leapt upon me
i loved a girl sonja but the vampire
visited me
and i sickened and died and awoke then i
arose
it is the curse of the undead to prey
upon those they love
i visited sonia i made her my own
she too died and for a brief while we
walked the earth together
neither alive nor dead but that was not
sonja
it was her body yes but i had not loved
her body alone
i realized too late that i had destroyed
her utterly
one day they opened her grave and the
priest drove a stake through her heart
and gave her rest me they could not find
for my coffin was hidden too well i put
love behind me then
knowing that there was none for such as
i
hope came to me when i found gene
hundreds of years have passed since
sonya crumbled to dust
but i thought i had found her again and
i took her
nothing human could prevent me the
chevalier's eyelid sagged
he looked infinitely old nothing human
yet in the end i found that i could not
condemn her to the hell that is mine
i thought i had forgotten love but long
and long ago
i loved sonia and because of her and
because i know that i would only destroy
as i once did before i shall not work my
will on this girl
i turn to watch the still figure on the
couch
the chevalier followed my gaze and
nodded slowly
yes she bears the stigmata she will die
unless he met my gaze unblinkingly
unless i die if you had broken into the
vault yesterday
if you had sunk that knife into my heart
she would be free now
he glanced at the windows again the sun
will rise soon
then he went quickly to gene's side he
looked down at her for a moment
she is very beautiful he murmured too
beautiful for hell
the chevaliers swung about went toward
the door
as he passed me he threw something
carelessly on the table
something that tinkled as it fell in the
portal he paused
and a little smile twisted the scarlet
lips
i remembered him thus framed against the
black background of the doorway
his sleek blonde head erect and unafraid
he lifted his arm at a gesture that
should have been theatrical
but somehow wasn't and so farewell
i who am about to die he did not finish
in the faint grayness of dawn i saw him
striding away
heard his footsteps on the stairs
receding and faint
heard a muffled clang as of a great door
closing
the paralysis had left me i was
trembling a little
for i realized what i must do soon but i
knew i would not fail
i glanced down at the table even before
i saw what lay beside the knife
i knew what would be there a silver key
the village of maxley where last summer
in autumn these strange events took
place
lies on a heathery and pineclade upland
of sussex
in all england you could not find a
sweeter and saner situation
should the wind blow from the south it
comes laden with the spices of the sea
to the east high downs protect it from
the inclemencies of march
and from the west and north the breezes
which reach it travel over miles of
aromatic forest and heather
the village itself is insignificant
enough in point of population
but rich in amenities and beauty halfway
down the single street with its broad
road and spacious areas of grass on each
side
stands the little norman church and the
antique graveyard
long disused for the rest there are a
dozen small sedate georgian houses
red bricked and long windowed each with
a square of flower garden in front
and an ampler strip behind a score of
shops
and a couple of score of thatched
cottages belonging to laborers on
neighboring estates
complete the entire cluster of its
peaceful habitations
the general peace however is sadly
broken on saturdays and sundays
for we lie on one of the main roads
between london and brighton
and our quiet street becomes a race
course for flying motor cars and
bicycles
a notice just outside the village
begging them to go slowly
only seems to encourage them to
accelerate their speed
for the road lies open and straight and
there is really no reason why they
should do otherwise
by way of protest therefore the ladies
of maxley cover their noses and mouths
with their handkerchiefs as they see a
motorcar approaching
though as the street is asphalted they
need not really take these precautions
against dust
but late on sunday night the horde of
scorchers has passed
and we settle down again to five days of
cheerful and leisurely seclusion
railway strikes which agitate the
country so much leave us
undisturbed because most of the
inhabitants of maxley never leave it at
all
i am the fortunate possessor of one of
these small georgian houses
and consider myself no less fortunate in
having so interesting and stimulating a
neighbor
as francis ircombe who the most
confirmed of max leitz
has not slept away from his house which
stands just
opposite to mine in the village street
for nearly two years
at which date though still in middle
life he resigned his physiological
professorship
at cambridge university and devoted
himself to the study of those
occult and curious phenomena which seem
equally to concern the physical
and the psychical sides of human nature
indeed his retirement was not
unconnected with his passion for the
strange
uncharted places that lie on the
confines and borders of science
the existence of which is so stoutly
denied by the more materialistic minds
for he advocated that all medical
students should be obliged to pass some
sort of examination in mesmerism
and that one of the tripos papers should
be designed to test their knowledge
in such subjects as appearances at time
of death haunted houses
vampirism automatic writing and
possession
of course they wouldn't listen to me ran
his account of the matter
for there is nothing that these seats of
learning are so frightened of as
knowledge
and the road to knowledge lies in the
study of things like these
the functions of the human frame are
broadly speaking
known they are a country anyhow that has
been charted and mapped out
but outside that lie huge tracts of
undiscovered country
which certainly exist and the real
pioneers of knowledge are those who
at the cost of being derided as
credulous and superstitious
want to push on into those misty and
probably perilous places
i felt that i could be of more use by
setting out without compass or knapsack
into the mists than by sitting in a cage
like a canary
and chirping about what was known
besides teaching is very bad for a man
who knows himself only to be a learner
you only need to be a self-conceited ass
to teach
here then in francis ircombe was a
delightful neighbor to one who
like myself has an uneasy and burning
curiosity
about what he called the misty in
perilous places
and this last spring we had a further
and most welcome addition to our
pleasant little community
in the person of mrs amworth widow of an
indian civil servant
her husband had been a judge in the
northwest provinces
and after his death at peshawar she came
back to england
and after a year in london found herself
starving for the antler air and sunshine
of the country
to take the place of the fogs and
griminess of town
she had too a special reason for
settling in maxley
since her ancestors up till 100 years
ago had long been native to the place
and in the old churchyard now disused
are many gravestones bearing her maiden
name of chaston
big and energetic her vigorous and
genial personality speedily woke maxley
up
to a higher degree of sociality than it
had ever known
most of us were bachelors or spinsters
or elderly folk not much inclined to
exert ourselves in the expense and
effort of hospitality
and hitherto the gaiety of a small tea
party with bridge afterwards and
galoshes when it was wet
to trip home in again for a solitary
dinner was about the climax of our
festivities
but mrs amworth showed us a more
gregarious way and set an example of
luncheon parties and little dinners
which we began to follow on other nights
when no such hospitality was on foot
a lone man like myself found it pleasant
to know that a call on the telephone to
mrs amworth's house
not a hundred yards off and an inquiry
as to whether i might come over after
dinner for a game of pk
before bedtime would probably evoke a
responsive welcome
there she would be with a comrade-like
eagerness for companionship and there
was a glass of port
and a cup of coffee and a cigarette and
a game of pk
she played the piano too in a free and
exuberant manner
and had a charming voice and sang to her
own accompaniment
and as the days grew long and the light
lingered late we played our game in her
garden which in the course of a few
months she had turned from being a
nursery for slugs and snails
into a glowing patch of luxuriant
blossoming
she was always cheery and jolly she was
interested in everything
and in music in gardening in games of
all sorts
was a competent performer everybody
with one exception liked her everybody
felt her to bring with her the tonic of
a sunny day
that one exception was frances ircombe
he
though he confessed he did not like her
acknowledged that he was vastly
interested in her
this always seemed strange to me for
pleasant and jovial as she was
i could see nothing in her that could
call forth conjecture or intrigued
surmise
so healthy and unmysterious a figure did
she present
but of the genuineness of urcom's
interest there could be no doubt
one could see him watching and
scrutinizing her
in matter of age she frankly volunteered
the information that she was 45
but her briskness her activity her
unravaged skin
her cold black hair made it difficult to
believe that she was not adopting an
unusual device
and adding 10 years onto her age instead
of subtracting them
often also as our quite unsentimental
friendship
ripened mrs amworth would ring me up and
propose her advent
if i was busy writing i was to give her
so we definitely bargained a frank
negative
in an answer i could hear her jolly
laugh and her wishes for a successful
evening of work
sometimes before her proposal arrived
ircombe would already have stepped
across from his house opposite for a
smoke and a chat and he
hearing who my intended visitor was
always urged me to beg her to come
she and i should play our pk said he and
he would look on
if we did not object and learn something
of the game
but i doubt whether he paid much
attention to it for nothing could be
clearer than that
under that penthouse of forehead and
thick eyebrows his attention was fixed
not on the cards but on one of the
players
but he seemed to enjoy an hour spent
thus and often
until one particular evening in july he
would watch her with the air of a man
who has some deep problem in front of
him
she enthusiastically keen about our game
seemed not to notice his scrutiny then
came that evening
when as i see in the light of subsequent
events began the first twitching of the
veil
that hid the secret horror from my eyes
i did not know it then
though i noticed that thereafter if she
rang up to propose coming round
she always asked not only if i was at
leisure but whether mr irkom was with me
if so she said she would not spoil the
chat of two old bachelors
and laughingly wish me good night irkome
on this occasion
had been with me for some half an hour
before mrs amworth's appearance
and had been talking to me about the
medieval beliefs concerning vampirism
one of those borderlands subjects which
he declared had not been sufficiently
studied
before it had been consigned by the
medical profession to the dust heap of
exploded superstitions
there he sat grim and eager tracing with
that polluted clearness which had made
him in his cambridge days so admirable a
lecturer
the history of those mysterious
visitations in the mall there were the
same general features
one of those ghoulish spirits took up
its abode in a living man or woman
conferring supernatural powers of
bat-like flight
and glutting itself with nocturnal blood
feasts
when its host died it continued to dwell
in the corpse
which remained undecayed by day it
rested
by night it left the grave and went on
its awful errands
no european country in the middle ages
seemed to have escaped them
earlier yet parallels were to be found
in roman and greek and in jewish history
it's a large order to set all that
evidence aside as being moonshine he
said
hundreds of totally independent
witnesses in many ages have testified to
the occurrence of these phenomena
and there's no explanation known to me
which covers all the facts
and if you feel inclined to say why then
if these are facts do we not come across
them now
there are two answers i can make you one
is that there were diseases known in the
middle ages
such as the black death which were
certainly existent then
and which have become extinct since but
for that reason we do not assert that
such diseases ever existed
just as the black death visited england
and decimated the population of norfolk
so here in this very district about 300
years ago
there was certainly an outbreak of
vampirism and maxley was the center of
it
my second answer is even more convincing
for i tell you that vampirism is by no
means extinct now
an outbreak of it certainly occurred in
india a year or two ago
at that moment i heard my knocker plied
in the cheerful and peremptory manner in
which mrs amworth is accustomed to
announce her arrival
and i went to the door to open it come
in at once
i said and save me from having my blood
curdled
mr irkom has been trying to alarm me
instantly her vital voluminous presence
seemed to fill the room
ah but how lovely she said i delight in
having my blood curdled
go on with your ghost story mr irkom i
adore ghost stories
i saw that as his habit was he was
intently observing her
it wasn't a ghost story exactly said he
i was only telling our host how
vampirism was not extinct yet
i was saying that there was an outbreak
of it in india only a few years ago
there was a more than perceptible pause
and i saw that if erkom was observing
her
she on her side was observing him with
fixed eye and parted mouth
then her jolly laugh invaded that rather
tense silence
oh what a shame she said you're not
going to curdle my blood at all
where did you pick up such a tale mr
ircome i have lived for years in india
and never heard a rumor of such a thing
some storyteller in the bazaars must
have invented it they are famous at that
i could see that irkome was on the point
of saying something further
but checked himself ah very likely that
was it
he said but something had disturbed our
usual peaceful sociability that night
and something had damped mrs amworth's
usual high spirits
she had no gusto for pk and left after a
couple of games
ircombe had been silent too indeed he
hardly spoke again until she departed
that was unfortunate he said for the
outbreak of of a very mysterious disease
let us call it
took place at peshawar where she and her
husband were
and well i asked
he was one of the victims of it said he
naturally i had quite forgotten that
when i spoke
the summer was unreasonably hot and
rainless and maxley suffered much from
drought
and also from a plague of big black
night flying gnats
the bite of which was very irritating
and virulent
they came sailing in of an evening
settling on one's skin
so quietly that one perceived nothing
till the sharp stab announced that one
had been bitten
they did not bite the hands or face but
chose always the neck and throat for
their feeding ground and most of us
as the poison spread assumed a temporary
goiter
then about the middle of august appeared
the first of those mysterious cases of
illness
which our local doctor attributed to the
long continued heat
coupled with the bite of these venomous
insects
the patient was a boy of 16 or 17 the
son of mrs amworth's gardener
and the symptoms were an anemic pallor
and a languid prostration
accompanied by great drowsiness and an
abnormal appetite
he had too on his throat two small
punctures
where so dr ross conjectured one of
these great gnats had bitten him
but the odd thing was that there was no
swelling or inflammation around the
place where he had been bitten
the heat at this time had begun to abate
but the cooler weather failed to restore
him
and the boy in spite of the quantity of
good food which he so ravenously
swallowed
wasted away to a skin-clad skeleton
i met dr ross in the street one
afternoon about this time
in an answer to my inquiries about his
patient he said that he was afraid the
boy was dying
the case he confessed completely puzzled
him some obscure form of pernicious
anemia was
all he could suggest but he wondered
whether mr irkom would consent to see
the boy
on the chance of his being able to throw
some new light on the case
and since ircombe was dining with me
that night i proposed to dr ross to join
us
he could not do this but said he would
look in later
when he came irkhome at once consented
to put his skill at the other's disposal
and together they went off at once being
the shorn of my sociable evening i
telephoned to mrs
amworth to know if i might inflict
myself on her for an hour
her answer was a welcoming affirmative
and between pk and music
the hour lengthened itself into two she
spoke of the boy who was lying so
desperately and mysteriously ill
and told me that she had often been to
see him taking him nourishing and
delicate food
but today and her kind eyes moistened as
she spoke
she was afraid she had paid her last
visit
knowing the antipathy between her and
irkom i did not tell her that he had
been called in a consultation
and when i returned home she accompanied
me to my door for the sake of a breath
of night air
and in order to borrow a magazine which
contained an article on gardening which
she wanted to read
ah this delicious night air she said
luxuriously sniffing in the coolness
night air and gardening are the great
tonics there is nothing so stimulating
as bare contact with rich mother earth
you are never so fresh as when you've
been grubbing in the soil
black hands black nails and boots
covered with mud
she gave her great jovial laugh i'm a
glutton for air and earth
she said positively i look forward to
death
for then i shall be buried and have the
kind earth all around me
no lead in caskets for me i've given
explicit directions
but what shall i do about air well i
suppose one can't have everything
the magazine a thousand thanks i will
faithfully return it
good night garden and keep your windows
open and you won't have anemia
i always sleep with my windows open said
i
i went straight up to my bedroom of
which one of the windows looks out over
the street
and as i undressed i thought i heard
voices talking outside not far away
but i paid no particular attention put
out my lights
and falling asleep plunged into the
depths of a most horrible dream
distortedly suggested no doubt by my
last words with mrs amworth
i dreamed that i woke and found that
both my bedroom windows were shut
half suffocating i dreamed that i sprang
out of bed
and went across to open them the blind
over the first was drawn down
and pulling it up i saw with the
indescribable horror of incipient
nightmare
mrs amworth's face suspended close to
the pain
and the darkness outside nodding and
smiling at me
pulling down the blind again to keep
that terror out i rushed to the second
window on the other side of the room
and there again was mrs amworth's face
then the panic came upon me in full
blast here was eyes suffocating in the
airless room
and whichever window i opened mrs
amworth's face would float in
like those noiseless black gnats that
bit before one was aware
the nightmare rose to a screaming point
and with strangled yells i awoke to find
my room
cool and quiet with both windows open
and blinds up
and a half moon high in its course
casting an oblong of tranquil light on
the floor
but even when i was awake the horror
persisted and i lay
tossing and turning i must have slept
long before the nightmare seized me for
now it was nearly day
and soon in the east the drowsy eyelids
of morning began to lift
i was scarcely downstairs next morning
for after the dawn i slept late
when irk home rang up to know if he
might see me immediately
he came in grim and preoccupied and i
noticed that he was pulling on a pipe
that was not even filled
i want your help he said and so i must
tell you first of all of what happened
last night
i went round with the little doctor to
see his patient and found him just alive
but scarcely more
i instantly diagnosed in my own mind
what this anemia
unaccountable by any other explanation
meant
the boy is the prey of a vampire
he put his empty pipe on the breakfast
table by which i had just sat down
and folded his arms looking at me
steadily from under his overhanging
brows
now about last night he said i insisted
that he should be moved from his
father's cottage into my house
as we were carrying him on a stretcher
whom should we meet but mrs amworth
she expressed shock's surprise that we
were moving him
now why do you think she did that with a
start of horror
as i remembered my dream that night
before i felt an idea come into my mind
so preposterous and unthinkable that i
instantly turned it out again
i haven't the smallest idea i said
then listen while i tell you about what
happened later
i put out all light in the room where
the boy lay and watched
one window was a little open for i had
forgotten to close it
and about midnight i heard something
outside trying apparently to push it
farther open
i guessed who it was yes it was full 20
feet from the ground
and i peeped round the corner of the
blind just outside was the face of mrs
amworth
and her hand was on the frame of the
window very softly i crept close
and then banged the window down and i
think i just caught the tip of one of
her fingers
but it's impossible i cried how could
she be floating in the air like that
and what did she come for don't tell me
such
once more with closer grip the
remembrance of my nightmare sees me
i am telling you what i saw said he and
all night long until it was nearly day
she was fluttering outside like some
terrible bat
trying to gain admittance now put
together various things i have told you
he began checking them off on his
fingers number one
he said there was an outbreak of disease
similar to that which this boy is
suffering from at peshawar
and her husband died of it number two
mrs amworth protested against my moving
the boy to my house
number three she or the demon that
inhabits her body
a creature powerful and deadly tries to
gain admittance
and add this too in medieval times there
was an epidemic of vampirism here at
maxley
the vampire so the account's run was
found to be elizabeth chaston
i see you remember mrs amworth's maiden
name
finally the boy is stronger this morning
he would certainly not have been alive
if he had been visited again
and what do you make of it there was a
long silence
during which i found this incredible
horror assuming the hues of reality
i have something to add i said which may
or may not bear on it
you said that the the spectre went away
shortly before dawn
yes i told him of my dream and he smiled
grimly
yes you did well to awake he said that
warning came from your subconscious self
which never wholly slumbers and cried
out to you of deadly danger
for two reasons then you must help me
one to save others
the second to save yourself what do you
want me to do
i asked i want you first of all to help
me in watching this boy
and ensuring that she does not come near
him eventually i want you to help me in
tracking the thing down in exposing and
destroying it
it is not human it is an incarnate fiend
what steps we shall have to take i don't
yet know
it was now eleven of the four noon and
presently i went across to his house for
a
hour vigil while he slept to come on
duty again that night
so that for the next 24 hours either
irkom or myself
was always in the room where the boy now
getting stronger every hour
was lying the day following was saturday
and a morning of brilliant polluted
weather
and already when i went across to his
house to resume my duty
the stream of motors down to brighton
had begun
simultaneously i saw irkom with a
cheerful face
which boated good news of his patient
coming out of his house
and mrs amworth with a gesture of
salutation to me and a basket in her
hand
walking up the broad strip of grass
which bordered the road
there we all three met i noticed
and saw that irkome noticed it too that
one finger of her left hand was bandaged
good morning to you both said she and i
hear your patient is doing well mr irkom
i've come to bring him a bowl of jelly
and to sit with him for an hour
he and i are great friends i'm overjoyed
at his recovery
ircombe paused a moment as if making up
his mind and then shot out a pointing
finger at her
i forbid that he said you shall not sit
with him or see him
and you know the reason as well as i do
i have never seen so horrible a change
pass over a human face
as that which now blanched hers to the
color of a grey mist
she put up her hand as if to shield
herself from that pointing finger
which drew the sign of the cross in the
air and shrank back
cowering onto the road there was a wild
hoot from a horn
a grinding of breaks a shout too late
from a passing car
and one long scream suddenly cut short
her body rebounded from the roadway
after the first wheel had gone over it
and the second followed it lay there
quivering and twitching
and was still she was buried three days
afterwards in the cemetery outside
maxley in accordance with the wishes she
had told me that she had devised about
her interment
and the shock which her sudden and awful
death had caused to the little community
began by degrees to pass off to two
people only
irkom and myself the horror of it was
mitigated from the first by the nature
of the relief that her death brought
but naturally enough we kept our own
counsel and no hint of what greater
horror had been thus averted was ever
let slip
but oddly enough so it seemed to me he
was still not satisfied about something
in connection with her
and would give no answer to my questions
on the subject
then as the days of a tranquil mellow
september and the october that followed
began to drop away like the leaves of
the yellowing trees
his uneasiness relaxed but before the
entry of november
the seeming tranquility broke into a
hurricane
i had been dining one night at the far
end of the village and about 11 o'clock
was walking home again
the moon was of an unusual brilliance
rendering all that it's shown on as
distinct as in some etching
i had just come opposite the house which
mrs amworth had occupied
where there was a board up telling that
it was tillette when i heard the click
of her front gate
and next moment i saw with a sudden
chill and quaking of my very spirit
that she stood there her profile
vividly illuminated was turned to me and
i could not be mistaken in my
identification of her
she appeared not to see me indeed the
shadow of the u-hedge in front of her
garden
enveloped me in its blackness and she
went swiftly across the road
and entered the gate of the house
directly opposite
there i lost sight of her completely my
breath was coming in short pants as if i
had been running
and now indeed i ran with fearful
backward glances
along the hundred yards that separated
me from my house and her combs it was to
his that my flying steps took me
and next minute i was within what have
you come to tell me
he asked or shall i guess you can't
guess
said i no it's no guess she has come
back
and you have seen her tell me about it
i gave him my story that's major
parasol's house
he said come back with me there at once
but what can we do i asked i've no idea
that's what we've got to find out
a minute later we were opposite the
house when i had passed it before it was
all dark
now lights gleamed from a couple of
windows upstairs
even as we faced it the front door
opened and next moment major parasol
emerged from the gate
he saw us and stopped i'm on my way to
dr ross
he said quickly my wife has been taken
suddenly ill
she had been in bed an hour when i came
upstairs and i found her white as a
ghost and utterly exhausted
she had been to sleep it seemed but you
will excuse me
one moment major said irkom was there
any mark on her throat
how did you guess that said he there was
one of those beastly gnats must have
bitten her twice there
she was streaming with blood and there's
someone with her
asked erkom yes i roused her maid
he went off and erkom turned to me i
know now what we have to do
he said change your clothes and i'll
join you at your house
what is it i asked i'll tell you on our
way
we're going to the cemetery he carried a
pic
a shovel and a screwdriver when he
rejoined me and wore around his
shoulders a long coil of rope
as we walked he gave me the outlines of
the ghastly hour that lay before us
what i have to tell you he said will
seem to you now too
fantastic for credence but before dawn
we shall see whether it outstrips
reality
by a most fortunate happening you saw
the spectre the astral body
whatever you choose to call it of mrs
amworth going on its grisly business
and therefore beyond doubt the vampire
spirit which abode in her during life
animates her again in death that is not
exceptional
indeed all these weeks since her death i
have been expecting it
if i am right we shall find her body
undecayed and untouched by corruption
but she has been dead nearly two months
said i
if she had been dead two years it would
still be so if the vampire has
possession of her
so remember whatever you see done it
will be done not to her
who in the natural course would now be
feeding the grasses above her grave
but to a spirit of untold evil and
malignancy which gives a phantom life to
her body
but what shall i see done said i i will
tell you
we know that now at this moment the
vampire clad in her mortal semblance is
out
dining out but it must get back before
dawn and it will pass into the material
form that lies in her grave
we must wait for that and then with your
help i shall dig up her body
if i am right you will look on her as
she was in life
with the full vigor of the dreadful
nutriment she has received pulsing in
her veins
and then when dawn has come and the
vampire cannot leave the lair of her
body
i shall strike her with this and he
pointed to his pick
through the heart and she who comes to
life again only with the animation the
fiend gives her
she and her hellish partner will be dead
indeed
then we must bury her again delivered at
last
we had come to the cemetery and in the
brightness of the moonshine there was no
difficulty in identifying her grave
it lays some 20 yards from the small
chapel in the porch of which
obscured by shadow we concealed
ourselves
from there we had a clear and open sight
of the grave and now we must wait till
its infernal visitor returned home
the night was warm and windless yet even
if a freezing wind had been raging
i think i should have felt nothing of it
so intense was my preoccupation as to
what the night and the dawn would bring
there was a bell in the turret of the
chapel that struck the quarters of the
hour
and it amazed me to find how swiftly the
chimes succeeded one another
the moon had long set but a twilight of
stars shone the clear sky
when five o'clock of the morning sounded
from the turret
a few minutes more passed and then i
felt ircombe's hand softly nudging me
and looking out in the direction of his
pointing finger i saw that the form of a
woman
tall and large and billed was
approaching from the right
noiselessly with emotion more of gliding
and floating than walking
she moved across the cemetery to the
grave which was the center of our
observation
she moved round it as if to be certain
of its identity
and for a moment stood directly facing
us
in the grayness to which now my eyes had
grown accustomed i could easily see her
face
and recognize its features she drew her
hand across
her mouth as if wiping it and broke into
a chuckle of such laughter as made my
hair
stir on my head then she leaped onto the
grave
holding her hands high above her head an
inch by inch disappeared into the earth
irkom's hand was laid on my arm in an
injunction to keep still
but now he removed it come he said
with pick and shovel and rope we went to
the grave the earth was light and sandy
and soon after six strikes we had delved
down to the coffin lid
with his pick he loosened the earth
round it and adjusting the rope through
the handles by which it had been lowered
we tried to raise it
this was a long and laborious business
and the light had begun to herald day in
the east
before we headed out and lying by the
side of the grave
with his screwdriver he loosened the
fastenings of the lid and slid it aside
and standing there we looked on the face
of mrs amworth
the eyes once closed in death were open
the cheeks were flushed with color
the red full lipped mouth seemed to
smile
one blow and it's all over he said you
need not look
even as he spoke he took up the pick
again and laying the point of it on her
left breast
measured his distance and though i knew
what was coming
i could not look away he grasped the
pick in both hands
raised it an inch or two for the taking
of his aim and then with full force
brought it down on her breast a fountain
of blood
though she had been dead so long spouted
high in the air
falling with the thud of a heavy splash
over the shroud and simultaneously from
those red lips
came one long appalling cry swelling up
like some hooting siren
and dying away again with that
instantaneous as a lightning flash
came the touch of corruption on her face
the color of it faded to ash
the plump cheeks fell in the mouth
dropped
thank god that's over said he and
without pause slipped the coffin lid
back into its place
day was coming fast now and working like
men possessed
we lowered the coffin into its place
again and shoveled the earth over it
the birds were busy with their earliest
pipings as we went back to maxley
you